>> HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
LAST WEEK...
>> LET'S BRING OUT THE FANS.
>> HI. I'M KASIA.
>> JASON.
>> MONIQUE SAID
THAT YOU WOULD KISS ME.
>> OKAY.
>> WHOA. YOU BETTER WATCH IT.
>> ALEXANDRIA, YOU SHOULD'VE
NEVER KISSED THE CHEEK.
>> WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
SOMEONE ELSE TELLS THAT PERSON
THAT I WOULD DO THAT?
>> THAT'S IT.
>> BEAUTIFUL. LOVE THIS.
>> IS THERE ANY WAY
YOU CAN MOVE YOUR ARM?
>> OH, YOU'RE DROPPING...
>> PLEASE LEAVE HER ARM
THE WAY THAT IT IS.
I PUT IT THERE ON PURPOSE.
CHIN UP A BIT, MONIQUE, THOUGH.
DON'T BRING IT BACK IN.
>> MONIQUE--IF YOU TOOK HER
OUT OF THIS PICTURE,
THE PICTURE'S JUST AS STRONG.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
>> MONIQUE WAS SENT HOME.
SEVEN GIRLS REMAIN,
BUT ONLY ONE WILL HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH IMG, COVERGIRL,
AND APPEAR ON THE PAGES
OF ITALIAN "VOGUE."
WHO DO YOU THINK
WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ON TOP ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> ♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT HOT ♪
♪ GET IT UP ♪
♪ YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT WE DON'T STOP ♪
♪ NA, AND WHEN YOU GET IT HOT ♪
♪ NA, YOU GOTTA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
WANNA BE ON TOP?
WHOO!
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
(static hisses)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> YEAH.
>> I WAS REALLY JUST SICK
OF GETTING RUNNER-UP
AND TRYING SO HARD
AND JUST STOP BEING RUNNER-UP,
AND I DID IT, SO...
>> BRITTANI.
>> I FINALLY GOT BEST PHOTO
THIS WEEK.
>> FIRST TIME
THAT YOU'RE CALLED FIRST.
>> AND I'M REALLY, REALLY HAPPY
AND EXCITED,
BUT I REALLY WAS SHOCKED
WHEN ALEXANDRIA
WAS NOT IN THE BOTTOM TWO.
ALEXANDRIA SHOULD HAVE
WENT HOME AT PANEL.
THERE'S NOT WORDS FOR HOW MUCH
I JUST DON'T LIKE THIS GIRL.
SHE'S COMPLETELY RUDE
AND DISRESPECTFUL.
SO IT'S JUST A MATTER OF TIME
BEFORE THE TRUE COLORS SHOW OUT,
AND THEY'RE LIKE, NO.
>> I WAS NOT EXPECTING TO BE
IN THE BOTTOM TWO WITH MONIQUE.
I JUST--I'M JUST TIRED OF, LIKE,
SHOWING UP AT PANEL,
I KNOW I'M DOING MY BEST,
AND THEN I GET THIS
RIDICULOUS PHOTOS THAT, LIKE...
>> ARE DIFFERENT.
>> WHATEVER.
MONIQUE AND I DID NOT EXPECT
TO BE IN THE BOTTOM TWO,
SO IT WAS DEFINITELY
A SURPRISE TO ME.
>> MIKAELA.
>> I'M A LITTLE PISSED OFF,
TO BE HONEST.
I HAVE BEEN MODELING
SINCE I WAS 15.
I DO THINK I HAVE
MORE EXPERIENCE
THAN A LOT OF THE GIRLS HERE,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
I'M GOING TO PANEL
AND I DON'T SEE GREAT SHOTS.
IT'S FRUSTRATING.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> BRITTANI!
LOOK AT YOUR PICTURE!
>> HEY.
>> WHAT IS THIS?
>> WHAT IS ALL OF THAT?
>> OH! NEW LITTLE THINGS!
>> YEAH.
>> OOH!
>> TAKE ONE?
>> SO WE GET HOME FROM PANEL,
AND WE SEE
THESE CUTE LITTLE RED BAGS
ALL LINED UP WITH SYMBOLS.
EVERYONE'S TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE DOING.
WHO THE HECK KNOWS?
>> "WARRIORS IN PINK.
POWERED BY FORD."
>> WOW. THIS IS NICE!
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS.
>> EVERYTHING IN HERE
WENT TOWARDS BREAST CANCER.
>> OH, MY GOD. THAT IS...
>> WE ALL GRABBED BAGS,
AND WE LOOK IN THEM,
AND IT'S ALL
THE WARRIORS IN PINK CLOTHING,
WHICH IS FOR THE SUSAN G. KOMEN
RACE FOR THE CURE
FOR BREAST CANCER AWARENESS.
>> I'VE HAD
TWO REALLY CLOSE FRIENDS...
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> GO THROUGH BREAST CANCER,
AND, UH, THE ONE'S GOING THROUGH
RADIATION RIGHT NOW,
AND THE ONE...
I DO KNOW TWO WOMEN BACK HOME
THAT HAVE FOUGHT BREAST CANCER,
SO I WAS REALLY EXCITED.
I'M LIKE, OH, COOL.
WE'RE GONNA DO SOMETHING
FOR A CAUSE, WHICH IS AWESOME.
>> I DON'T WANT TO GO IN THERE.
I DON'T EVEN WANT
TO SEE HER RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T EVEN WANNA LOOK
AT HER FACE.
ALEXANDRIA--DEFINITELY UP THERE
IN MY TOP MOST ANNOYING BITCHES
EVER.
>> CROSS IT OVER AND STEP AGAIN.
NOW DO IT ONE MORE TIME.
UM, THE THING WITH RAW CHICKEN
IS, UM, YOU HAVE TO WRAP IT.
I KNOW THAT.
>> DOES IT HURT? LET ME SEE.
>> NO. I DON'T EVEN WANNA
THINK ABOUT MY LIP RIGHT NOW.
OH, MY GOD.
THERE WAS A TOWEL RIGHT HERE.
WHO PICKED IT UP?
>> WE DON'T REALLY NEED
TO TALK ABOUT THE FRUSTRATION
AND THE PROBLEMS RIGHT NOW.
WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON THE COMMERCIAL.
>> NO, BECAUSE--
BUT I'M THE TALENT.
>> DRIVES ME NUTS WITH EVERY
SINGLE THING THAT SHE DOES.
I AM SO SICK AND TIRED OF IT.
I'M READY FOR HER TO GO HOME,
AND THEN WE'LL ALL BE OKAY.
>> PEOPLE OBVIOUSLY
WANTED ME TO GO HOME,
AND I'M FEELING ATTACKED.
I'M NOT GONNA LET IT AFFECT ME.
I'M JUST GETTING WARMED UP.
AND THE MORE THAT THESE GIRLS
HAVE TO SAY NEGATIVELY,
IT'S JUST GONNA BE MORE FUEL
FOR MY FIRE, BITCHES.
>> AAH!
>> NIGEL!
>> HI, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> WELCOME TO SMASHBOX STUDIOS.
I'M SURE YOU'VE ALL FIGURED OUT
BY NOW THAT TODAY
YOU'RE GONNA BE DOING YOUR PART
FOR THE FIGHT AGAINST
BREAST CANCER.
WELL, FOR THE PAST 17 YEARS,
FORD MOTOR COMPANY
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
SUSAN G. KOMEN FOR THE CURE,
AND THEY'VE CREATED
THE FORD WARRIORS IN PINK
CAMPAIGN.
FORD HAS ALREADY DEDICATED
$110 MILLION
TO THE BREAST CANCER CAUSE.
THE APPAREL YOU'RE WEARING IS
AVAILABLE AT fordcares.com,
AND 100% OF THE NET PROCEEDS
GO TO THE CAUSE.
NOW THE FORD
WARRIORS IN PINK CAMPAIGN
IS DESIGNED TO RECOGNIZE
THE STRENGTH AND COURAGE
IT TAKES TO DEAL
WITH THE EVERYDAY CHALLENGES
OF FIGHTING BREAST CANCER.
THE SYMBOLS EMBODY
THE STRENGTH AND THE SPIRIT
OF WARRIORS WHO LIVE, BREATHE,
AND FIGHT AGAINST THIS DISEASE.
YOU'VE ALL CHOSEN
A SYMBOL ALREADY,
AND YOU'LL BE EMBODYING
THE MEANING OF THAT SYMBOL
IN A PHOTO SHOOT CHALLENGE
WITH ME.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO PICK OUT
YOUR OWN HAIR, YOUR OWN MAKEUP,
YOUR OWN STYLING.
THE GIRL WHO DOES THE BEST JOB
IS GOING TO APPEAR
IN A FORD WARRIORS IN PINK
PRINT AD
THAT'S GONNA BE NATIONWIDE.
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY
TO BE A TRUE ROLE MODEL.
>> OH, I WANT TO WIN
THE CHALLENGE SO BAD.
YOU KNOW, JUST THE CHANCE
TO REALLY BE A ROLE MODEL--
IT'S A HUGE DEAL.
>> LET'S GO TO HAIR AND MAKEUP.
>> FOR SAFETY, LET'S MAYBE
JUST DO THE STRONG EYE
AND THE LIP...
>> YEAH.
AND THEN LATER ON WE CAN SMEAR.
I PICKED
THE WARRIOR OF COURAGE SYMBOL,
AND I'M GONNA THINK
JUST ABOUT MY AUNT
AND HOW MUCH HER STRUGGLING
THROUGH BREAST CANCER
MAKES ME REALLY WANT
TO TAKE IT DOWN.
I WANTED THE DARK MAKEUP,
THE MESSY, LOOK LIKE I'M READY
TO GET IN THAT BOXING RING
AND FIGHT BREAST CANCER.
>> WHEW. COOL.
I LOVE THAT LITTLE MESSAGE.
LET'S SEE IF YOU CAN EMBODY IT.
(bell dings)
(camera shutter clicking)
>> WHAT ARE YOU THINKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW?
>> BEATING THE CRAP
OUT OF BREAST CANCER.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> WELL DONE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YEAH, WELL DONE.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> JUST LIKE THIS.
GOOD. BEAUTIFUL.
WE GOT IT. WE'RE GOOD.
GORGEOUS. WELL DONE.
>> MY SYMBOL IS THE DOVE.
I DID JUST GET BEST PHOTO,
AND SO I KNOW THAT I HAVE
THAT THING IN MY EYES THAT
I CAN REALLY GIVE IT TO THEM
AND SHOW THEM EMOTION.
AND I REALLY FEEL LIKE
I'M GONNA DO WELL TODAY
AND I HAVE A CHANCE TO WIN.
(camera shutter clicking)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WHAT ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
WHEN YOU LOOK INTO THE CAMERA?
>> I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T THINK
WHEN I LOOK INTO THE CAMERA.
I JUST DO.
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE NO WORDS FOR WHAT I DO.
I CAN'T EXPLAIN IT.
>> YOU CAN'T EMOTE IN A PICTURE
IF YOU'RE JUST DOING.
AS A ROLE MODEL AND SPOKESPERSON
FOR A CHARITY, YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
DID SHE? NO.
THIS IS ABOUT EMOTING.
YOU CAN'T JUST DO PASSION.
YOU HAVE TO BE
PASSIONATE.
♪♪♪♪♪
(camera shutter clicks)
>> WHAT ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
WHEN YOU LOOK INTO THE CAMERA?
>> I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T THINK
WHEN I LOOK IN THE CAMERA.
I JUST DO.
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> I AM REALLY PASSIONATE
FOR THE PHOTO I'M TAKING.
I FELT LIKE I WAS GIVING
A LOT OF EMOTION,
AND THEN HE TELLS ME
I'M NOT DOING ANYTHING.
IT REALLY HURT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> (sighs)
>> YOU'VE BEEN PRACTICING.
>> YES. I WANT IT TO LOOK COOL.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> RELAX. RELAX.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> OBVIOUSLY, THE B--
THE ACTION LOOKS GOOD.
THAT WORKS.
BUT DON'T FORGET TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
HANNAH LOOKED FANTASTIC,
BUT SHE GOT SO WRAPPED UP
WITH THE WHOLE SPIRAL IDEA
THAT IT BECAME MUCH MORE
ABOUT MAKING A SPIRAL
THAN ACTUALLY OWNING IT
IN HER EYES.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO YOU,
A CAMPAIGN LIKE THAT?
>> (crying) KNOWING M-MY NIECE
DOESN'T HAVE
ONE OF HER GRANDMOTHERS.
>> OH, YOU KNOW, THOSE ARE...
>> I KNOW.
>> YOU KNOW, EXTREMELY EMOTIONAL
AND EXTREMELY MOVING,
AND THINK ABOUT
WHAT IT MEANS TO YOU,
WHAT IT--HOW'S IT'S AFFECTED
OTHER PEOPLE,
AND BREAST CANCER DOES AFFECT,
UM, SADLY,
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE EVERY YEAR.
>> I REALLY WANTED TO BE
THE WARRIOR, AND I-I WANTED
TO BRING SOME SOFTNESS,
BUT I DEFINITELY DIDN'T WANT
TO BRING IT DOWN BY CRYING
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
I REALLY WANTED TO MAKE IT
A STRONG SYMBOL.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> MIKAELA CAME TO SET,
AND SHE HAD THE SPEAR.
SHE HAD A GREAT OUTFIT ON.
SHE KEPT DOING THE SAME THING
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
IT WAS QUITE FRUSTRATING.
CAN YOU CHANGE IT UP AGAIN?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WHAT ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
RIGHT NOW?
>> UM, MY PARENTS' FRIEND DEE,
WHO DIED.
>> BE THERE FOR HER.
BE THAT ANGEL.
>> IT MEANS A LOT TO ME
TO WIN THIS CHALLENGE, UM,
NOT ONLY BECAUSE
IT'S A GREAT MESSAGE
TO SEND OUT TO PEOPLE,
BUT IT WOULD BE A HUGE DEAL
JUST 'CAUSE I HAVEN'T WON
ANY CHALLENGES YET.
DAMN IT.
>> ARE YOU OUR LAST GIRL?
YOU ARE, AREN'T YOU?
>> YEAH.
>> YOU SAVED THE MESSY ONE
FOR LAST.
>> YES.
>> COME ON, YOU.
>> I CHOOSE THE TREE OF LOVE.
IT REPRESENTS THE PEOPLE
THAT GROW AND STAY STRONG
THROUGH ANYTHING
THAT'S THROWN THEIR WAY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SHE WAS DOING THE SAME THING
SHE ALWAYS DOES
IN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
LIKE, I CAN'T EVEN DO IT,
'CAUSE IT'S SUCH A WEIRD,
FREAKIN' FACE.
I JUST WANTED HER TO GO AWAY
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH
NEGATIVE ENERGY IN ME
BECAUSE OF HER.
>> GORGEOUS.
>> I DON'T THINK
IT'S THAT GREAT.
>> HE DOES, THOUGH.
>> GORGEOUS. HOLD IT.
WE GOT IT. WE'RE GOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BEAUTIFUL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WELL DONE, YOU.
OKAY, GIRLS.
IT WAS A GREAT CAUSE,
SO YOU SHOULD BE PROUD
OF YOURSELF
FOR WHAT YOU DID TODAY.
MIKAELA, WHEN YOU CAME TO SET,
YOU KNOW, YOU LOOKED BEAUTIFUL,
BUT YOU WERE VERY WRAPPED UP
IN POSING WITH THE ACTUAL SPEAR,
NOT REALIZING THAT YOU WANTED
TO EMOTE YOUR SYMBOL.
HANNAH, IT WAS INTERESTING,
BUT IT WASN'T THAT MEMORABLE
FOR ME.
SO WHEN I WAS THINKING
ABOUT ALL THE PICTURES,
YOU KNOW...
WHAT WAS HANNAH'S SHOT AGAIN?
>> I DON'T LIKE BEING
CONSIDERED UNMEMORABLE
BECAUSE I AMMEMORABLE.
I AM FREAKING HOUSTON, TEXAS,
RIGHT HERE.
I LAUGH AT THAT.
I DON'T ACCEPT THAT AT ALL.
>> BRITTANI, I GOT YOU UP THERE,
AND I SAID TO YOU QUITE SIMPLY,
"WHAT ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT?"
AND YOU SAID STRAIGHT TO ME...
>> NO, I DON'T THINK
WHEN I LOOK IN THE CAMERA.
I JUST DO.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO BE IN CONTROL.
YOU GOTTA BE PASSIONATE.
YOU GOTTA HAVE HEART.
THIS IS A MESSAGE.
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT MODELING.
ALEXANDRIA, I THOUGHT YOU DID
A VERY INTERESTING JOB.
I LOVED THE IDEA
WITH THE MUD ON THE GROUND.
I THINK YOU MADE IT YOUR OWN.
YEAH, IT WAS A LITTLE OBVIOUS.
"TREE OF LOVE.
I'M GONNA BE A TREE."
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
SOMETIMES WE CAN DO THE OBVIOUS,
AS LONG AS YOU'RE COMMITTED
WITH THE EYES
AND YOUR HEART AND SOUL
AND YOUR EMOTION WAS THERE.
AND I FELT THAT IN THE PICTURE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE WINNER TODAY
IS GOING TO APPEAR
IN A NATIONAL AD CAMPAIGN
FOR FORD WARRIORS IN PINK,
AND YOU'RE GONNA BE
DOING A P.S.A.
THERE CAN ONLY BE ONE.
ALEXANDRIA,
YOU ARE THE WINNER.
>> I END UP WINNING
THE CHALLENGE,
AND MR. BARKER GETS
TO SHOOT MY AD,
AND I CAN'T BELIEVE...
>> (mouths word)
>> THAT I'M GONNA BE
A POSITIVE ROLE MODEL.
>> SO BEFORE WE GET STARTED,
I'LL GO AND GET YOUR COSTAR.
GIVE ME A MOMENT.
>> ♪ UHH! UHH! UHH-UHH! UHH ♪
♪ YEAH, YEAH ♪
♪ UHH! UHH! UHH! ♪
>> OH, YES,
THIS IS YOUR COSTAR--
THE 2012 FORD FOCUS.
DON'T WANT TO SCRATCH IT
'CAUSE IT'S YOURS.
YOU READY?
>> NO.
>> COME IN.
COME. LET'S HAVE A LOOK.
>> WHAT?
>> COME AND HAVE A LOOK
AT THE CAR. IT'S YOURS.
>> YOU'RE LYING.
>> I'M NOT LYING.
>> THIS IS POTENTIALLY ONE
OF THE BIGGEST PRIZES
WE'VE EVER HAD ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
AND I AM NOT LYING TO YOU.
YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
>> I DON'T HAVE A CAR.
>> WELL, NOW YOU DO. WELL DONE.
>> THANK YOU.
I GET TO BE A PART
OF WARRIORS IN PINK FOR FORD.
ABOVE ALL, I GET A CAR.
(honks horn)
>> (laughs)
(crying) I'M REALLY HAPPY
THAT I WON THIS IS GONNA PROVE
TO EVERYONE THAT
I CAN MAKE IT THROUGH,
AND KEEP POSITIVE
NO MATTER WHAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, FORD.
>> AND WE'RE GONNA SHOOT
AN AD CAMPAIGN RIGHT NOW.
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHTY?
>> I'M READY. (chuckles)
>> YOU'RE READY? LET'S DO IT.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> I REALLY, REALLY THINK
THAT NIGEL MADE
THE WRONG DECISION CHOOSING
ALEXANDRIA AS THE WINNER,
BECAUSE ONE, I DON'T THINK
SHE'S VERY ATTRACTIVE,
TWO, I DIDN'T THINK
SHE LOOKS LIKE A MODEL.
>> YOU PICKED THE UGLIEST
(bleep) PERSON HERE
AS FAR AS THEIR SOUL.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> AND THAT THEY'RE EMBODYING
SOMETHING THAT MEANS SO MUCH
AND SHE'S SO (bleep) FAKE.
>> IT'S (bleep). EXACTLY.
>> IT'S WRONG AND IT UPSETS ME.
>> DUMBEST (bleep)
I'VE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE.
>> NO, BUT--
>> I JUST WANT
SOMEONE THAT DESERVES IT.
>> MM-HMM.
>> SOMEONE THAT'S A GOOD PERSON.
>> ANY OTHER PERSON IN THE ROOM.
>> ANY OTHER PERSON
I WOULD'VE BEEN SO HAPPY FOR.
>> I CAN HEAR YOU.
>> I DON'T (bleep) CARE
IF YOU CAN HEAR ME.
>> THAT'S REALLY RUDE.
>> IT SHOULD'VE CAME OUT,
LIKE, TEN (bleep) WEEKS AGO.
>> YOU DON'T DESERVE
TO BE HERE ANYMORE.
>> YOU SHOULD'VE WENT HOME
LAST NIGHT INSTEAD OF MONIQUE.
>> YEP. WE ALL AGREE.
>> THEN DON'T BE FAKE
WHEN YOU'RE ASKING ME
HOW I'M DOING.
>> I'M NOT BEING (bleep) FAKE
WHEN I ASK YOU THAT.
I'M BEING NICE.
>> NO, YOU'RE NOT.
>> BECAUSE THIS WHOLE TIME...
>> NO, YOU'RE NOT, BECAUSE THEN
YOU WANTED ME TO BE HOME.
>> I DID NOT WANT TO BE MEAN
AND SAY, "HEY, ALEXANDRIA,
YOU'RE FAKE."
>> NO, I'M NOT. YOU ARE.
>> I'M FAKE BECAUSE I'M NICE?
>> YOU'RE NOT NICE.
THAT'S NOT NICE.
THE WAY YOU'RE TALKING TO ME
IS NOT NICE EITHER.
>> AND SO THEN EVERY OTHER ONE
OF THESE GIRLS HERE IS FAKE,
TOO, BECAUSE THEY'RE NICE
TO YOU BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO SINGLE YOU OUT?
WE ALL GAVE YOU A CHANCE.
>> I DON'T CARE. I--
>> IF YOU DON'T CARE, THEN
HOW ABOUT YOU JUST STOP TALKING?
>> THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT NEED
TO GIVE ME A CHANCE ARE
THE PEOPLE THAT MAKE--
THAT MATTER.
YOU GUYS ARE IN THE COMPETITION
AS WELL.
>> OKAY. THAT'S FINE.
>> THAT'S FINE, ABSOLUTELY.
I DON'T NEED YOU.
>> "I'M FINE." (mutters)
>> I NEED THE JUDGES AND...
THE PEOPLE THAT I WORK WITH.
>> WE DON'T--WE DON'T CARE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I JUST WON
THE 2012 FORD FOCUS,
AND MY FAVORITE FEATURE IS
THE MyFord TOUCH.
AND I GET TO CONTROL IT
WITH THE TOUCH OF MY FINGERS
AND THE SOUND OF MY VOICE,
AND I CAN'T WAIT TO TRY IT OUT.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> I DON'T HATE HER,
'CAUSE I DON'T HATE ANYONE,
BUT I REALLY DON'T LIKE HER.
>> I JUST LAUGH HER OFF.
PEOPLE LIKE THAT,
YOU HAVE TO LAUGH OFF.
I DON'T THINK SHE DESERVED
TO WIN THE PRIZE.
I KNOW THAT WE ALL WANTED IT,
AND I REALLYWANTED IT.
SO IT'S--IT'S UPSETTING
THAT I DIDN'T WIN.
>> OKAY, EITHER WE--
WE GIVE IT TO HER
AND TELL HER EVERYTHING...
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> OR WE JUST GIVE HER
THE SILENT TREATMENT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I JUST DON'T GET IT.
I DON'T GET WHAT I'VE DONE.
WHEN I WIN A... CHALLENGE
FINALLY,
NO ONE FEELS HAPPY FOR ME.
I'M STRONG.
I'M ALPHA.
I'M THE LIONESS.
I'M GETTING WHAT I WANT
BECAUSE I'M GONNA DO IT
NO MATTER WHAT.
>> WAKE UP!
WAKE UP!
(high-pitched voice, singsongy)
WAKE UP, SLEEPYHEADS!
(normal voice) GET UP, GET UP.
MORNING!
>> I HEAR THIS NOISE
THAT'S LIKE...
(high-pitched voice) "WAKE UP,
BITCHES! IT'S TIME TO GO!"
(normal voice) I'M LIKE, WHAT?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
IS THAT MISS J.?
>> I HAVE JUST SCORED US
V.I.P. TREATMENT
AT UNIVERSAL STUDIOS.
>> OH!
>> SO WE'RE GONNA GO ON A TOUR.
I HAVE NEVER BEEN THERE MYSELF.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WE ARE GOING ON
A LITTLE FIELD TRIP
TO UNIVERSAL STUDIOS.
IT'S REALLY COOL TO HAVE A DAY
WHERE WE CAN JUST HAVE FUN
AND HANG OUT WITH MISS J.
>> OKAY, GOOD MORNING,
LADIES AND J.
WELCOME ABOARD
FOR A SPECIAL EDITION
OF THE STUDIO TOUR.
AND ON THE LEFT,
IT'S THE SLEEPY LITTLE TOWN
OF AMITY ISLAND FROM "JAWS."
>> AAH!
>> VERY LITTLE
IS WHAT IT APPEARS TO BE
HERE IN HOLLYWOOD.
(horror movie music playing)
>> OH, MY GOD! "PSYCHO."
THIS MOVIE TERRORIZED
MY BLACK ASS FOR LIFE.
>> SINCE YOU LIKE "PSYCHO"
SO MUCH AND HITCHCOCK,
MAYBE YOU CAN
GET OFF THE TRAM HERE
AND GET A PHOTO OP?
>> THIS IS MAJOR,DARLING,
(click)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (screechy voice)
YOU'RE NOT MODELING
"H" TO "T"!
>> AAH! OH!
>> YOU'RE NOT GIVING ME NECK!
>> OH!
>> AND WHERE THE HELL...
>> (grunts)
>> IS THE SMIZE?!
>> AAH! (cries)
WHY?!
WHY?! WHY?! W--
>> (normal voice) SOMETIMES
YOU JUST NEED
A LITTLE MORNING STABBING
JUST TO GET THROUGH
THE TENSION OF THE COMPETITION.
WHAT BETTER PLACE
TO BE SILLY AND ACT CRAZY
THAN THE BACKLOT
OF UNIVERSAL STUDIOS?
TODAY, I WANT YOU GIRLS
TO SHOW ME HOW CRAZY FOR FASHION
YOU REALLY ARE.
SO WHILE I SEND YOU GUYS
OFF TO HAIR AND MAKEUP,
I'M GONNA GIVE MISS J.
HER DRESS BACK
AND PUT ON SOMETHING
A LITTLE MORE FITTING
TO INTRODUCE YOU TO
YOUR VERY SPECIAL GUEST STYLIST
AND PHOTOGRAPHER.
SO I'LL SEE YOU IN A MOMENT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HEY, GUYS.
WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
I WANTED TO INTRODUCE YOU GUYS
TO MIGUEL,
WHO'S GONNA BE
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY.
MIGUEL STARCEVICH
IS A VERY CREATIVE
AND AVANT-GARDE PHOTOGRAPHER,
AND HE HAS WORKED WITH CLIENTS
FROM "FLAUNT" TO "InStyle."
>> I DON'T WANT YOU GUYS
TO HOLD BACK AT ALL.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I WANT YOU TO COME WITH IT
VERY ITALIAN "VOGUE."
I WANT YOU ALL
TO BE SUPERSTARS TODAY.
>> THE MORE EXTREME
THAT YOU GO WITH THIS,
THE BETTER.
I KNOW TENSIONS ARE HIGH
IN THE COMPETITION RIGHT NOW,
SO KINDA USE THIS SHOOT
AS, LIKE--LIKE,
A CATHARTIC KIND OF MOMENT...
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> JUST TO KINDA HELP
PUSH THROUGH
ALL OF THAT ANXIETY.
BUT WE DO HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST
HERE TODAY.
YOU GUYS HAVE ALL SEEN
"GOSSIP GIRL," I'M SURE,
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE, UH,
ERIC DAMAN HERE,
WHO IS THE STYLIST
OF "GOSSIP GIRL."
ERIC? THERE HE IS.
>> HELLO!
>> HEY, GIRLS.
>> WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING
WITH ERIC DAMAN,
AND HE STYLES
THE GIRLS IN "GOSSIP GIRL."
THAT'S ONE OF MY FAVORITE,
FAVORITE, FAVORITE SHOWS,
AND I'M FREAKING OUT.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> HOW IMPORTANT ARE THE CLOTHES
FOR THE SHOOT TODAY?
>> THE CLOTHES--I WANTED TO
KIND OF CONVEY, LIKE, A COSTUME
FOR THE CHARACTER.
I WANTED TO, YOU KNOW,
KIND OF HELP YOU GUYS
CREATE CHARACTERS.
THAT'S WHAT I DO ON THE SHOW
AS A COSTUME DESIGNER.
THE CLOTHES HELP YOU BECOME WHO
THIS PERSON IS SUPPOSED TO BE.
>> ALL OF YOU ARE GONNA HAVE
AN INDIVIDUAL THEME,
AND IT'S LITERALLY
SOMEBODY'S CRAZY FOR FUR,
SOMEONE'S CRAZY FOR BAGS,
SOMEONE'S CRAZY FOR SHOES.
IT'S LITERALLY A "CRAZY FOR."
>> TODAY, WE'RE GOING
REALLY DARK AND DRAMATIC
AND USING MORE MATTE...
>> THAT'S FINE WITH ME.
>> TO GIVE CONTOURING
AND--AND DIMENSION.
>> MOLLY WAS OUR
"CRAZY FOR ACCESSORIES" GIRL.
>> THIS IS TOP-HEAVY.
>> IT'S TOP-HEAVY.
>> I'M LIKE...
>> MOLLY SEEMED
A LITTLE BIT AWKWARD, UM,
BECAUSE OF ALL THE ACCESSORIES.
IF YOU'RE CRAZY FOR ACCESSORIES,
THEN YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO WORK THAT,
AND YOU CAN'T JUST SAY,
"WELL, I FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE
'CAUSE I HAVE
ALL THESE ACCESSORIES ON ME."
>> RIGHT NOW,
YOU LOOK SUPER UNCOMFORTABLE.
I KNOW THAT
IT'S NOT COMFORTABLE,
BUT I DON'T WANT YOU
TO WEAR THAT AWKWARDNESS
IN YOUR PHOTO.
SCHLUFF ALL THAT OFF, OKAY?
>> OKAY.
>> SEXY. THERE WE GO. OWN IT.
LOVE IT.
CHIN UP JUST A LITTLE BIT.
RIGHT THERE. RIGHT THERE.
>> (hissing)
(inhales deeply)
>> I LOVE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
WITH YOUR BODY,
BUT "CRAZY" DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN... (hisses)
>> YEAH.
>> I THINK I PROBABLY
COULD'VE DONE BETTER.
I THINK I TRIED TO BRING
A LITTLE TOO MUCH CRAZY
INSTEAD OF SEXY.
>> HOLD THAT. RIGHT THERE.
LOVE THAT. I THINK WE GOT IT.
>> YEAH?
>> THANK YOU!
>> (screaming)
>> NICE.
LET'S SEE YOUR FACE. BEAUTIFUL.
GREAT. LOVE IT.
I LOVED BRITTANI.
BRITTANI WAS REALLY COOL.
SHE CAME OUT, LIKE,
KICKING AND JUMPING LIKE,
YOU KNOW, KARATE KID,
AND SHE HAD A GREAT PERSONALITY.
NICE.
>> GOOD JOB.
WHY--WHY ARE YOU
IN SUCH A GREAT MOOD TODAY?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST LIKE SHOES.
>> (laughs)
>> GOOD.
>> YOUR HAT IS REALLY,
REALLY GREAT. YOU LIKE IT?
>> HMM. YEAH, I LOVE
THE LITTLE ACCESSORIES
ON THE TOP.
>> OH, YEAH, I ADDED
THE LITTLE BUTTERFLY BROOCH.
>> IT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR ME TO MAKE AN IMPRESSION
AND BE SOMEONE
WHO WILL BE REMEMBERED.
SO IT'S... IMPERATIVE
THAT I DO WELL TODAY.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> OKAY, HOLD THAT.
HOLD THAT RIGHT THERE.
LOVE THAT.
>> HAVE FUN.
>> I LOVE BAGS SO MUCH!
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY AMAZING!
>> GOOD.
>> THIS IS HOT, CRAZY MESS.
>> I THINK I STARTED
LOSING MYSELF
IN THE THEATRICS OF IT ALL.
AND I CAN JUST HEAR MR. JAY,
AND HE DOESN'T REALLY SOUND
TOO HAPPY.
THIS IS NOT GOOD.
BAGS! AND BAGS!
>> WAIT. HOLD ON.
>> AND BAGS.
>> AND RIGHT NOW,
I'M FEELING VERY...
FORCED IN THE HAND AND THE BAG.
IT'S A LITTLE FORCE-FED.
HANNAH TRIED TO GIVE
HER INTERPRETATION OF "CRAZY"
AND LEFT "MODEL"
UP IN HAIR AND MAKEUP.
(circus music playing)
>> HOLD ON. LOVE THAT.
REMEMBER,
YOU'RE "CRAZY FOR MAKEUP."
GOOD. LOVE THAT.
LOVE THAT. GOOD.
>> YOU ACTUALLY KINDA
GIVE ME CRAZY QUITE NATURALLY.
ARE YOU A LITTLE CRAZY?
>> (laughs)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> PLAY WITH IT.
GOOD. GOOD.
YEAH, DO THAT. THAT'S GOOD.
>> I LIKE THE FACT THAT KASIA
WASN'T AFRAID TO FROWN
AND DO THINGS
THAT WERE DIFFERENT.
>> GREAT.
>> (laughs)
>> GREAT. OH, I LOVE THAT.
SELL THE BAGS. SELL THE FURS.
>> IT'S A LITTLE SHY OF CRAZY.
WHAT MAKES YOU CRAZY?
>> WHEN PEOPLE ARE
YELLING AT ME.
>> WELL, I'M NOT GONNA
STAND HERE AND YELL AT YOU.
I CAN GET A COUPLE OF GIRLS,
THOUGH, FOR YOU.
>> NO. NO, THEY'VE DONE
ENOUGH OF THAT.
>> OH, THEY HAVE?
>> YEAH.
>> THOSE BITCHES ARE
DRIVING YOU NUTS.
YOU'RE GOING CRAZY.
WHAT DO YOU GOT?
>> AAH!
>> BETTER. YOU'RE NUTS.
YOU'RE IN A CRAZY HOUSE.
>> AAH!
>> LOOK HOW BEAUTIFUL
THAT ONE IS.
THAT WAS GORGEOUS.
>> GOOD.
>> AAH!
>> ALEXANDRIA NEEDS
TO LEAVE ALREADY.
>> I DON'T THINK
IT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
>> IT WON'T.
ONE OF US IS GOING HOME.
>> YEAH.
>> NOT LIKE YOU AND ME,
BUT PROBABLY ME, YEAH.
>> WHO KNOWS?
I WAS IN THE (bleep) BOTTOM TWO
LAST WEEK
FOR SOME STRANGE REASON.
♪♪♪♪♪
(camera shutter clicking)
>> (gasps)
OH!
>> COME UP LITTLE BIT, HONEY.
SEE IT. GOOD.
>> (gasps)
>> I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
JUST LOOKING AND GOING,
"I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO GO FOR."
>> 'CAUSE THERE'S JUST
SO MUCH STUFF. EXACTLY.
>> YEAH, ALLOW THE SET
TO SERVE YOU...
>> RIGHT.
>> INSTEAD OF LETTING IT
OVERTAKE YOUR ENERGY.
>> OKAY.
>> MIKAELA WAS JUST OVERWHELMED
BY THE SET.
SO IT ALMOST WAS LIKE
UNWRAPPING PRESENTS
ON CHRISTMAS MORNING,
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO.
>> YEAH. DO THAT AGAIN.
>> (gasps)
>> THAT'S A WRAP, EVERYBODY.
>> OH, GOOD.
>> WE'RE GOOD.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HOW'D EVERYBODY'S SHOOTS GO?
>> LIKE, I GOT ON SET,
AND THERE WAS ALL THESE BAGS
IN FRONT OF ME,
AND I WAS LIKE...
I'M NERVOUS ABOUT PANEL.
I FEEL LIKE I DID A GOOD JOB,
BUT IT WAS NOT THE BEST
THAT I COULD'VE DONE.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE A FEW OF US
DID GREAT,
AND THEN A FEW OF US DID GOOD
AND THEN ENDED GREAT.
AND WE ALL LOOK BETTER
THAN THAT.
>> I ACTUALLY STARTED GOOD.
>> AND THEREFORE,
SHE IS GOING HOME.
IF SHE DOESN'T GO HOME
THIS WEEK...
I-I REALLY HOPE
I DON'T FLIP OUT AT PANEL,
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE
THE WORST PLACE
FOR ME TO FLIP OUT.
I ALREADY FEEL REALLY BAD
FLIPPING OUT IN FRONT OF NIGEL,
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
HE'S GONNA LOOK AT ME
LIKE--LIKE I AMTHE BITCH,
AND THAT'S DEFINITELY
NOT HOW IT IS,
BECAUSE NOBODY ELSE SEES
EVERY SINGLE SIDE OF HER
THAT WE DO, LIVING WITH HER.
IF SHE CONTINUES
TO STAY IN THIS HOUSE,
I AM PROBABLY GONNA END UP
RIPPING OFF HER (bleep) HEAD.
>> THE GIRLS JUST
AREN'T TALKING TO ME,
WHICH I REALLY, FRANKLY, DON'T
REALLY WANT TO TALK TO THEM.
BRITTANI WANTED ME TO GO HOME.
WHO ARE YOU?
YOU DON'T MATTER TO ME.
I'M STRONG, AND YOU'RE WEAK.
BUT I WILL BE HERE LONGER.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I HAVE WEIRD BRA STUFF
HAPPENING.
THIS ONE IS SMALLER.
>> THIS SIDE IS SMALLER.
>> OKAY.
IT'S DEFINITELY
THE, UH, OPTICAL ILLUSION.
IT'S AN ILLUSION.
I'LL JUST CHANGE
BEHIND A CURTAIN.
I DON'T CARE.
AND DON'T FORGET BRAS.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HI, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> HELLO.
>> WELCOME TO ANOTHER JUDGING.
YOU KNOW OUR PRIZES--
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS,
A CONTRACT WITH IMG MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "VOGUE ITALIA,"
AND YOU'LL GET A COVER
OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE"
WITH A SPREAD,
LIKE OUR CYCLE 15 WINNER ANN,
AND PROMINENT FEATURE
ON vogue.it,
ITALIAN "VOGUE'S" WEB SITE.
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES--
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER,
ONE OF
THE MOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
IN ALL OF THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
MR. ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY,
AND THIS MAN, MR. ERIC DAMAN.
ERIC IS ONE OF THETOP STYLISTS
ON THE GLOBE.
HE GOT AN EMMY IN 2002
FOR "SEX AND THE CITY,"
AND HE IS THESTYLIST
FOR "GOSSIP GIRL."
(whispers) LET'S GO.
(normal voice) WHO'S FIRST?
HANNAH.
>> (chuckles)
>> YOU WERE A GIRL
THAT WAS OBSESSED WITH FASHION
AND HAD LOST HER MIND
AT A TEA PARTY.
AND WHAT ITEM OF FASHION
WERE YOU OBSESSED WITH?
>> (whispers) BAGS.
>> LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> I THINK YOU LOOK
ABSOLUTELY MAD.
IT JUST...
IT'S AS IF YOU WERE CAUGHT
ALMOST TRYING TO LEAVE
THE TEA PARTY WITH THE BAGS
'CAUSE YOU TOOK ALL THE BAGS
OF ALL THE GUESTS.
>> THIS PHOTO, I THINK,
IS ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC,
BUT YOUR FILM, HONEY...
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THE TIMING.
SO WHEN THE PHOTOGRAPHER
WAS CLICKING,
YOU WERE THIS...
NOT "LOOK HOW MY FACE.
I'M STILL TALKING,
BUT I'M AWAKE."
IT'S A DANCE. YOU WERE OFFBEAT.
THANK GOD
THAT YOU GOT THIS SHOT.
>> YES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT--MOLLY.
OBSESSED WITH...
>> ACCESSORIES.
>> I LOVE THIS PICTURE.
VERY COOL. VERY INTERESTING.
YOUR FACE--
I TOTALLY BELIEVE YOU.
I SEE ALL THE JEWELRY,
I SEE ALL THE ACCESSORIES,
YOU'VE SOLD THE PRODUCT,
BUT I ALSO SEE YOUR FACE.
>> I FEEL LIKE SHE WAS
SHOWING IT OFF REALLY,
REALLY WELL IN THE BEGINNING.
SHE--I THINK SHE FELT
A LITTLE AWKWARD
BECAUSE THERE WAS
A LOT OF ACCESSORIES ON HER,
WHICH REALLY TOOK HER A MINUTE
TO GET TO THAT POINT WHERE SHE--
WE GOT THIS SHOT.
I THINK IT LOOKS REALLY GREAT.
>> THERE'S A SENSUALITY
AND A LUNACY
TO THE WHOLE THING.
YOU GOTTA DO THIS MORE.
>> (whispers) OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT. THANKS.
>> (normal voice) THANK YOU.
>> JACLYN, COME ON DOWN HERE.
>> (whispers) EXCUSE ME.
>> AND WHAT WERE YOU CRAZY FOR?
>> (normal voice) I WAS
"CRAZY FOR MAKEUP."
>> LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> GORGEOUS. MAD.
(laughs)
COMEDIC AND WONDERFUL
AND BRILLIANT AND VERY EDGY
AND VERY EDITORIAL AT THE SAME.
>> JACLYN, I THINK THIS IS
THE BEST PICTURE
I'VE EVER SEEN OF YOU.
YOU LOOK LIKE THE JOKER.
>> YOUR FACE, GIRL,
IS SO GOOD
AND CRAZY.
YOU DID THIS FRAME AFTER FRAME
AND PROFILE, WIDE SHOTS.
YOU DID IT FOR ME.
>> THANK YOU.
UP NEXT--MIKAELA.
SO, MIKAELA,
YOU WERE OBSESSED WITH...
>> SALES.
>> SALES. HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> YOU HAD A HARD TIME
GETTING INTO IT
AND KINDA FINDING THAT MOMENT.
AND THEN, YOU KNOW, I THINK
IT REALLY TOOK YOU A MOMENT
TO TRY TO FIND, YOU KNOW,
A VERY HIGH FASHION POSE
IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL THIS.
I DON'T THINK THAT NECESSARILY
CAME ACROSS AS MUCH AS W--
AS WELL AS I WOULD'VE LIKED
TO SEEN IT.
>> WHAT WERE YOU THINKING
AND WHAT WERE YOU TRYING TO DO?
>> WHEN I FIRST GOT ON SET,
I IMMEDIATELY KINDA WANTED
TO TOUCH STUFF,
AND I THINK I WENT
A LITTLE TOO CRAZY WITH IT.
>> NOT CRAZY ENOUGH.
>> (mouths word)
>> THIS WAS THE CRAZIEST
THAT YOUR FACE GOT.
AS I WAS GOING THROUGH
YOUR FILM, IT MADE ME WONDER,
DID YOU UNDERSTAND
THE ASSIGNMENT
THAT THERE WAS
A CERTAIN LOOK OF PARANOIA
OR BEING DAZED
OR BEING OBSESSED,
BECAUSE... WASN'T THERE.
OKAY, THANK YOU.
UP NEXT IS KASIA.
YOU WERE OBSESSED WITH...
>> HAIR.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> I THINK YOU'RE LIKE
THE MAD SOCIALITE
AT THE HAIR SALON IN THE SOUTH.
I THINK YOU LOOK
ABSOLUTELY DERANGED.
>> WHAT I LOVE ABOUT IT IS
JUST YOUR EYES.
THEY'RE JUST COMPLETELY
ALMOST POPPING OUT OF YOUR HEAD.
>> I AGREE.
I THINK YOUR BODY LANGUAGE
LOOKS AMAZING.
AND WHEN WE WENT INTO IT,
YOU WERE HAVING SO MUCH FUN
AND TAKING RISKS AND, LIKE,
MESSING YOUR HAIR UP
AND GETTING IT
TO THIS KIND OF MAD PLACE.
IT JUST LOOKS GREAT.
>> NEXT UP IS ALEXANDRIA,
WHO WAS CHALLENGE WINNER.
>> WELL DONE.
SHE WAS INDEED.
AND SHE'S WEARING HER T-SHIRT.
>> YES.
>> FORD WARRIORS IN PINK.
>> AND YOU WERE OBSESSED WITH...
>> FUR. (chuckles)
>> I DO THINK
YOUR FACE LOOKS WONDERFUL...
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND I DO THINK THAT
YOU ARE MODELING.
I-I THINK IT WORKS.
>> I THINK
IT'S VERY HIGH FASHION.
IT LOOKS GORGEOUS.
YOU KNOW, THE OUTFIT'S CRAZY,
BUT I FEEL LIKE THERE'S
SOMETHING CRAZY MISSING
IN THE FACE.
>> THIS PHOTO--FOR IT TO BE
CRAZY TO ME, IT HAS TO HAVE
A WHOLE NARRATIVE
AND A WHOLE STORY.
DERANGED FOR FUR? IT'S NOT.
>> YOU DID A-A, UM,
AN AD FOR, UM,
FORD WARRIORS IN PINK.
THAT WAS A--
THAT WAS THE CHALLENGE.
THEY HAD TO EMBODY
THE--THE DIFFERENT SYMBOLS,
AND THEY DID A GOOD JOB.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
SOMETHING INTERESTING HAPPENED
THAT I WANTED TO BRING UP.
THERE WAS THIS SORT OF
EXTRAORDINARY PERFORMANCE
BETWEEN YOU AND BRITTANI.
WHAT WAS THAT ABOUT?
>> WE ALL KIND OF THINK THAT
AS FAR AS A ROLE MODEL GOES,
YOU REALLY CHOSE
THE WRONG SPOKESPERSON
BECAUSE WE SEE
THE TRUE ALEXANDRIA.
>> AS FAR AS BEING A ROLE MODEL
IS CONCERNED,
TO BE THAT OUTSPOKEN
AT A PHOTO SHOOT,
IN FRONT OF THE PHOTOGRAPHER,
IN FRONT OF THE CLIENTS--
BY THE WAY, FORD WERE THERE--
WAS EXTREMELY UNPROFESSIONAL.
THERE IS A REASON
WHY WE DON'T KNOW
ALL OF ALEXANDRIA'S BUSINESS.
IT'S BECAUSE WHAT YOU DO AT HOME
IS WHAT YOU DO AT HOME.
SO IT'S WORTH
BEARING THAT IN MIND,
BECAUSE NOW I, YOU KNOW,
I HAVE--I HAVE A DIFFERENT IDEA
ABOUT YOU.
>> THAT'S FINE.
>> BRITTANI,
WHY IN FRONT OF THE CLIENT?
>> (crying) I DIDN'T
CONFRONT HER. I WASN'T LIKE,
"OH, YOU DIDN'T DESERVE TO WIN."
I DIDN'T SAY THAT
WHENEVER THEY WERE DOING THAT.
>> YES, YOU DID, AND YOU...
>> I WAS TALKING WITH THEM,
AND SHE OVERHEARD, AND I'M NOT--
>> BUT THE CLIENT HEARD, SO...
>> AND I APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW--
WE WERE TALKING QUIETLY,
AND THEN ALEXANDRIA SAID, LIKE,
"I'M RIGHT HERE.
I CAN HEAR YOU."
>> "I CAN HEAR YOU."
>> I UNDERSTAND IT WAS
THE WRONG TI--THE WRONG TIME,
BUT I JUST FEEL HORRIBLE...
(sniffles) THAT I MADE MYSELF
LOOK LIKE A BAD--BAD PERSON
BECAUSE OF HOW I F--
LIKE, FELT ABOUT HER,
AND I AM JUST...
SO MAD AT MYSELF...
>> BRITTANI.
>> FOR LETTING HER
DO THIS TO ME.
>> BRITTANI. OKAY, WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ROLE MODELS, RIGHT?
ABOUT ROLE MODELS.
>> YEAH. YES.
>> IN TERMS
OF--OF--OF SPORTSMANSHIP,
WHAT YOU HAVE DONE IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE WEAKEST THINGS
THAT A ROLE MODEL COULD DO.
NO MATTER WHAT YOU FEEL INSIDE,
IF YOU THINK SOMEBODY ELSE IS
GETTING SOMETHING
THAT THEY DON'T DESERVE,
YOU SHUT YOUR LIPS,
ESPECIALLY IN FRONT OF A CLIENT.
THIS IS A BUSINESS.
YOU HAVE TO RESPECT THE CLIENT,
YOU HAVE TO RESPECT
YOUR COWORKERS,
AND YOU HAVE TO RESPECT
YOURSELF.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SO BRITTANI HAS LEFT,
BUT WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE.
THIS IS FASHION, DARLING.
BELIEVE ME, I'VE SEEN IT ALL.
>> WELL, A-ALEXANDRIA,
I FEEL VERY BAD FOR YOU,
STANDING HERE AND HEARING THIS,
AND I THINK YOU SHOULD
JUST BUCK UP
AND PUT A SMILE ON YOUR FACE.
>> (exhales deeply)
(sniffles)
>> (crying) LET'S JUST GO.
STAND.
>> BREATHE.
>> LET'S JUST DO IT
AND BE DONE.
>> OKAY.
>> (sniffles)
>> SO YOU LEFT THE SET
BECAUSE?
>> I'M HAVING A PANIC ATTACK.
I CAN'T REALLY TALK.
>> YOU'RE HAVING A PANIC ATTACK?
DO YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE JUDGES ARE TALKING ABOUT,
ABOUT YOU SPEAKING UP
IN FRONT OF A CLIENT?
>> I LEARNED TO KEEP MY MOUTH
SHUT WHEN I'M IN CERTAIN PLACES.
(sniffling)
>> OKAY.
AND WHAT WERE YOU DERANGED FOR
IN YOUR PHOTO SHOOT?
>> SHOES.
>> OKAY. HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> IT'S A VERY SWEET SHOT,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
I THINK YOU COULD'VE TAKEN IT
A LITTLE BIT BIGGER.
>> IT CERTAINLY ISN'T THE BEST
OF YOUR PHOTOS,
BUT IT WORKS BECAUSE I DO SEE
AN EMOTION IN THE EYES.
>> THANK YOU.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
IS ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SO NOW IT'S TIME
TO DELIBERATE.
FIRST UP--HANNAH.
>> I THINK THIS PICTURE
OF HANNAH, IT--IT WORKS
'CAUSE SHE DOES LOOK CRAZY.
SHE'S GOT THAT GREAT EXPRESSION
IN HER FACE,
AND SHE'S DEFINITELY EMOTING.
>> THE FACE
WITH THE "PSYCHO" HOUSE
IN THE BACKGROUND IS,
YOU KNOW, SPOT-ON.
>> SHE MANAGED TO CAPTURE
IN HER FACE SOME OF THE MADNESS.
IN A WAY, IT'S ALMOST
"ALICE IN WONDERLAND,"
BUT IT DOESN'T QUITE GET THERE.
>> MOLLY.
>> OFTEN WHEN I LOOK
AT ANY PHOTOGRAPH,
I AM THINKING,
"WHAT IS THE NARRATIVE?"
AS YOU SAID,
"WHAT IS THE STORY?"
THIS IS THE DERANGED SOCIALITE
WHO'S JUST COME HOME
FROM THE FUNERAL.
HER HUSBAND'S LEFT A FORTUNE.
SHE'S NOT SURE SHE SIGNED
THE RIGHT PRENUP.
SHE'S NOT SURE
SHE'S GETTING ALL THE MONEY.
I LOVE IT. IT'S PERFECT.
>> JACLYN.
>> IT'S A GENIUS SHOT.
SHE LOOKS STUNNING
AND SHE'S RAISED HER GAME.
>> SHE'S SO SWEET, LIKE,
GREAT LITTLE SOUTHERN BELLE.
I'M LIKE, HOW IS SHE GONNA GO
INTO THIS, LIKE,
CRAZY MAKEUP WORLD?
WHEN SHE GOT DOWN THERE,
SHE TURNED INTO THE JOKER
AND SHE TURNED IT OUT,
AND I THINK IT MIGHT BE ONE
OF THE BEST SHOTS OF THE DAY.
>> MIKAELA.
>> WELL, SHE SAID SHE WAS
OBSESSED WITH SALES.
IF YOU'RE OBSESSED WITH SALES,
SHE'S NOT SHOWING IT TO ME HERE.
THIS BAG SAYS "SALE."
WEAR THE BAG ON YOUR HEAD.
>> JUST GO LIKE THIS
IN THE EYES.
>> YEAH.
>> KASIA.
>> SHE WAS SO INTO IT,
AND I REALLY FELT LIKE
SHE WAS USING HER BODY
AND SHE WAS USING THE CHAIR
AND THE PROPS IN A VERY,
YOU KNOW, KIND OF
HIGH FASHION WAY, BUT ALSO HAVE,
YOU KNOW, THAT LOOK IN HER EYES.
>> THIS IS NEITHER COMMERCIAL
OR HIGH EDITORIAL,
BUT I STILL THINK KASIA
SHOULD BE IN THE RUNNING
BECAUSE SHE'S FIERCELY FABULOUS.
>> ALEXANDRIA.
>> ALEXANDRIA HAS NOT COME UP
TO THE CHALLENGE IN THIS PHOTO,
BUT I THINK SHE CAME UP
TO THE CHALLENGE
WITH DIGNITY TODAY IN THE DRAMA.
>> AS A PHOTOGRAPHER,
I-I LOOKED AT THIS, I'M, LIKE,
WOW, GREAT PICTURE.
BUT IF YOU DO A CLOSE-UP
ON THE FOX,
THE FOX IS EMOTING CRAZY EYES.
SHE JUST NEEDS TO EMBODY
THE FAUX FOX FUR EYES.
>> BRITTANI.
>> WELL, CERTAINLY HERE,
BRITTANI HAS NOT, UH,
SHOWN US MADNESS FOR SHOES.
>> BRITTANI HAS
AN EXTRAORDINARY BONE STRUCTURE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HER,
YOU SEE "MODEL."
BUT YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO MODEL.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
BRITTANI'S PERFORMANCE
AS--AS A HUMAN, AS A PERSON?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES,
BUT IT SHOULD NOT COME
TO THE WORKPLACE.
>> FOR ME, IT WAS
VERY DETRIMENTAL TO THE GIRL
THAT I MET YESTERDAY,
TO FIND THIS KIND OF THING OUT,
AND IT REALLY KIND OF CHANGED
MY OPINION ON HER.
>> I AGREE.
>> A LOT OF YOUNG GIRLS THINK
THAT THE OPPOSITE OF FAKE
IS RUDENESS,
AND JUST AS UGLY AS FAKE IS,
SO IS SAYING
WHATEVER IS ON YOUR MIND
BECAUSE IT'S THE "TRUTH."
>> DO YOU THINK
BRITTANI WILL LEARN
FROM HER LIFE LESSON HERE TODAY?
>> I HOPE THAT SHE CAN.
I LIKE TO THINK I HAVE FAITH
IN EVERYONE.
>> SHE STOOD IN FRONT OF US
IN THE MIDDLE OF, LIKE,
NOT BEING TO BREATHE.
THAT TOOK COURAGE, AND I FEEL
LIKE BECAUSE OF THAT COURAGE,
MAYBE SHE--SHE'S CAPABLE
OF CHANGE.
>> YOU GUYS ALL WANT ME
TO GO HOME,
BUT HERE'S THE THING--
I'M STILL HERE.
I STILL VERY MUCH WANT THIS.
YOU SHOULD'VE CAME TO ME.
DO ANY OF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH ME NOW?
>> I FEEL LIKE I'VE SEEN, LIKE,
FIVE DIFFERENT SIDE--
LIKE, PEOPLE FROM YOU.
YOU REALLY WERE BEING RUDE
TO PEOPLE ON SET...
>> YEAH.
>> AND, LIKE, WALKING
ALL OVER THEM, AND TO ME,
THAT'S WHAT OFFENDED ME.
>> WE WANT YOU TO GO HOME.
>> THAT'S FINE. THEN SEE,
THEN THAT'S WHAT YOU SHOULD SAY.
I COULD'VE STOPPED TALKING
TO ALL OF YOU A LONG TIME AGO.
(scoffs)
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
FAKELY NICE TO ME.
>> I WASN'T FAKELY NICE.
>> YEAH, BECAUSE NOW I LOOK LIKE
A (bleep) MORON WITH
ALL THE NICE THINGS
THAT I SAID ABOUT YOU GUYS.
EVERYONE'S PUT ON THIS FAÇADE
AND BEEN OKAY WITH ME,
WHEN YOU SHOULD'VE
JUST BEEN HONEST.
>> I WOULD NEVER
GO UP TO--TO SOMEONE AND S-SAY,
"I WANT YOU TO GO HOME."
>> YOU SHOULD'VE BEEN
JUST REAL WITH ME, GIRL.
>> ...
>> WHERE I'M NOT GONNA SAY
ANY NAMES...
>> I'M NOT (bleep) BEING
IN THIS (bleep) ROOM.
>> THERE IS SPUNK,
THERE IS ATTITUDE,
THERE IS, YOU KNOW,
CHARACTER IN BRITTANI
THAT CAN BE MOLDED.
>> THOUGH I CAN THINK BACK
TO THE TIME
THAT I DISAGREED THIS MUCH,
AND IT WAS WHEN TOCCARA,
SEASON 3, WAS VOTED TO GO HOME,
AND I WAS OUTVOTED.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK
WITH "TOP MODEL," THAT WE TALK,
AND THEN I DECIDE,
"OH, THIS IS WHO'S GOING HOME,"
BUT THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
I ALWAYS VOTE LAST.
>> YOU WERE RIGHT THEN.
>> WHAT, ABOUT TOCCARA?
>> YEAH, YOU WERE RIGHT.
SHE SHOULD'VE STAYED.
>> YOU THINK
SHE SHOULD'VE STAYED?
>> YEAH.
>> NO, YOU DON'T.
>> I DO NOW, WITH HINDSIGHT.
>> OKAY.
>> I THINK EVERYONE SHOULD
BE GIVEN A SECOND CHANCE.
I VOTE FOR BRITTANI TO STAY.
>> I VOTE FOR BRITTANI TO STAY.
>> AND I DON'T AGREE
WITH YOU GUYS.
>> SEVEN BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SIX PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE SIX OF YOU THAT ARE
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GONNA CALL IS
BEST PHOTO OF THE WEEK.
JACLYN.
>> (gasps)
(whispers) YES.
>> LOOK AT THAT GIRL
INSANE FOR THAT MAKEUP.
>> (normal voice) THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> RUNNER-UP FOR BEST PHOTO
GOES TO...
MOLLY.
ALMOST, MOLLY. ALMOST.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> (whispers) YOU'RE WELCOME.
(normal voice) HANNAH.
>> THE NEXT NAME I'M GONNA CALL
IS...
KASIA.
CONGRATULATIONS, KASIA.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME...
ALEXANDRIA.
YOU WOULDA BEEN CALLED
A LOT SOONER HAD YOU HAD
A LITTLE AHH
IN THOSE EYES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND YOU HANDLED YOURSELF
VERY WELL THIS WEEK.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
WILL BRITTANI AND MIKAELA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
TWO BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'LL ONLY CALL ONE NAME,
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
RETURN TO YOUR HOME,
PACK YOUR BAGS, AND GO.
SO...
MIKAELA, YOU HAVE A FACE
THAT THE JUDGES FIND
SO SPECTACULAR,
BUT THE ONE THING THAT'S LACKING
IS THAT INTENSITY IN THOSE EYES.
WE'VE SAID IT AGAIN AND AGAIN.
IT COMES, IT GOES.
YOUR SMIZE NEVER KNOWS
WHERE TO APPEAR.
AND THEN WE HAVE BRITTANI.
LAST WEEK, BEST PHOTO,
AND FROM WEEK TO WEEK,
SOME OF THE STRONGEST PHOTOS
OUT OF THE GIRLS HERE.
BUT WHAT MAKES HER UNATTRACTIVE
IS THE ATTITUDE
THAT WE SAW TODAY.
SO WHO STAYS
IN THIS COMPETITION?
PEOPLE THINK THAT ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
I'M THE ONLY PERSON
THAT MAKES A DECISION,
THAT I'M THE PERSON THAT SAYS
"THIS GIRL STAYS,
THIS GIRL GOES,"
AND THE JUDGES ARE JUST HERE
FOR COLOR COMMENTARY.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
IT HAS NEVER BEEN THE CASE.
AND THIS WEEK, I WAS OUTVOTED.
BRITTANI.
>> (crying)
I'M SORRY.
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> (whispers) I'M SORRY.
>> BRITTANI,
I HAVE A SERIOUS ISSUE
WITH HOW THESE JUDGES VOTED.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING ABOUT
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
I VOTE LAST.
THIS DOESN'T REST ON ME.
SO IF IT WAS JUST A MONARCHY,
MIKAELA WOULD BE STANDING
IN FRONT OF ME
AND YOU WOULD BE GOING HOME.
AND I WISH
THAT I COULD TELL YOU
THAT YOU NEED TO PROVE THIS
OR DO "X" OR DO "Y" OR DO "Z,"
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU CAN DO
TO PROVE THAT YOU DESERVE
TO BE HERE.
IT IS UP TO YOU
TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU. (sniffles)
>> I'M SORRY.
>> THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
OKAY, I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE MODELED BEFORE.
BUT YOU CAME TO "TOP MODEL"
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T HAPPEN AS BIG
OR AS AMAZING AS YOU WANTED TO.
AND YOU'RE THE KIND OF GIRL
THAT CAN GO INTO A GO-SEE
AND WOW, WOW, WOW,
JUST BY THE FACE,
BUT YOU DON'T WANT THEM
TO OPEN UP THE PORTFOLIO
AND GO, "EH, IT'S ALL RIGHT."
I STILL WISH YOU WERE HERE.
I REALLY, REALLY DO.
>> I KNOW.
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> IT WAS A REALLY CRAZY PANEL
TODAY.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO THINK,
BUT I KNEW MY PHOTO SHOOT
WASN'T AS GOOD
AS I WANTED IT TO BE,
AND IT'S ABOUT THE PHOTO.
I KNOW THAT BRITTANI HAD
A LITTLE MELTDOWN,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
WE'RE AT PANEL FOR A PHOTO,
AND MINE WASN'T BETTER
THAN HERS AND I-I KNEW THAT.
IT WAS JUST GREAT KNOWING THAT,
YOU KNOW, TYRA WAS
STILL SUPPORTING ME
AND STILL THINKS THAT
I CAN, YOU KNOW, DO THIS,
AND I MADE IT THIS FAR,
AND THAT'S A HUGE ACCOMPLISHMENT
TO ME.
♪♪♪♪♪
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.